welcome to star greets well today we're
doing a thing for star trees and I guess
at the end of the day we're going to
have something fantastic and I've so far
all I've seen bits and pieces and and
some really hopefully bang
look at that guy and like I say it's all
gonna break down around like you're
walking off a jet into a Sheldon so
they've got like six jokes for you to do
there and they're all short two liners
that everybody knows I love being
married having only one sex partner and
I'll tell you one she knows what I like
and I know what she won't do now you're
seeing it right just because you can see
me doesn't mean you're drunk
what did you're seeing two of them
you're probably drunk
that's a royal pain in the ass if
anybody ever asked you to do it huh I
guess that's how they do it in New York
huh I guess that's how they do it in
North Carolina huh I guess that's how
they do it in started tonight North
Dakota sortin I'm try to get south in
north and one nobody lives there anyway
a while back he a while back he paid me
to play it a while back he was
so we're gonna do it again great crew of
folks and really really made it as
painless as possible and I am turning
into an old grouch so they humored me
through the whole thing look up there
that's pretty good and if you want to
check out personalized Ron Wyatt
ringtones e cards and more and just
click the link just click on star drink
bit of starter eats is there any way you
can change the name of the company